explosive new court documents suggest
that former national security adviser
Mike Flynn was set up who he was set up
by Jim Comey handwritten notes unsealed
late tonight show the FBI discussed
using their January 2017 interview with
Flynn quote to get him to lie so we can
prosecute him or get him fired in other
words to entrap him and then ruin his
career and then of course later on get
it Trump
well the handwritten notes and with this
intriguing little snippet if we're seen
as playing games the White House will be
furious joining me now is congressman
Devin Nunez House Intel committee
ranking member and Sean Davis co-founder
of the Federalist congressman let's
start with you we've seen a lot of abuse
over the past three years you've been
digging into this and digging into it
but this has to be one of the more
egregious abuses of power given how this
we know this thing went down now your
thoughts well clearly general Flynn is
going to have a civil rights case and I
think it's going to cost the government
millions of dollars secondly hopefully
there's going to be some prosecutions
for this matter and the judge really has
an opportunity here to step in and
sanction these lawyers so and and with
all that said Laura we brought you this
the House Republicans brought you just a
snippet of this information back in 2018
we were mocked we were told it was a
joke well now all of a sudden he
realized that what we told you at that
time not only was it true we didn't even
know the half of it and even right now
we you don't even have the half of it
there's more information coming out the
rest of this week so that the evidence
is continuing to pile up in general
Flynn's general in favor which is what
we told you and what most of us knew
that have I've known general Flynn for
nearly 15 years and now to the idea that
he would be a Russian agent is
preposterous it's a disgrace and the way
this whole thing went down the meeting
went down the the interview was billed
it's just a conversation Sean here's
what Comey said about that fateful Flynn
interview back in two
18 we placed a call to Flynn said hey
we're sending a couple guys over hope
you'll talk to them
he said sure nobody else was there they
interviewed him in a conference room at
the White House Situation Room and he
lied to them and that's what he's now
pled guilty to what did he think they
were coming over there for I don't think
he knew I know we didn't tell him Sean
the hubris of call me I mean my blood
boils watching him his manner it manner
his you know is is pretty SHM an ER
there and his dismissiveness of the
rights of an individual you've been
digging into this tonight tell us your
thoughts right I I think it's clear now
that James Comey will go down in in
history as the most corrupt FBI director
in American history he has had the the
worst rain he has destroyed the FBI's
reputation through his actions his
arrogance and his corruption he has made
it more difficult according to a federal
prosecutor I spoke to today four US
Attorney's and FBI agents to get
convictions across the country and that
will forever be James commis legacy is
this corrupt coup that he attempted to
run against Donald Trump well remember
how this did go down congressman Nunez I
mean they did they called him I don't
know it was the White House Counsel
involved in this at all did don McGann I
don't know if he walked him over walk
Sally Yates oh I don't know how this
whole thing went down
but you do so remind us how it all went
down well let's remember the most
important thing in all of the Russia
hoax mess and we've heard about illegal
leaks well the most important leak at
the highest level or the transcripts of
Flynn have any private conversation the
incoming national security for the
President of the United States having a
conversation with the Russian ambassador
leaked out to the Washington Post and
other places I believe now why James
Comey and the FBI why 400 FBI agents
were crawling all over Washington DC
trying to find out oh my god we just
lost important take
the Russian ambassador here talking to
the National skin advisor somehow that
leaked out from the I see what did they
do they did nothing and and you to
answer your question what happened in
that in that process what they did is
they did not they had him a cave the
deputy FBI director call up general
Flynn and and say something like oh we
want to send a few people over there is
that okay so no they did not he did not
have legal counsel and they set him up
yeah whole thing was a setup
no it's Shawn the media they do not
escape culpability in all of this
because rather than being real
journalists they were rooted rooting
against this president and in his
administration from the start real quick
let's watch this guy was not only acting
as a foreign agent literally of as a
foreign agent not metaphorically
president from knew then what we all
know now that Flynn was a double agent
but the White House got was a blistering
rebuke of their made-up claims that
Flynn was somehow entrapped by the FBI
wasn't just the judge who did that it
was Michael Flynn well any of them come
on television tomorrow and apologize or
do a may of culpa Sean any of them well
any of them have that decency no it'll
never happen despite the fact that this
entire collusion hoax could never have
been perpetrated without their willing
work in it no they will never return
their Pulitzer Prizes that they got for
reporting fake news they will never
apologize they'll never admit they were
wrong ever much we're going to stay on
this tomorrow